well I think everyone listening to this
will know about calling out because it's
a culture that we have all fallen into
you know I'd be curious if anyone
listening to this thinks they have not
fallen into it somehow it's in many ways
the culture of social media in
particular but obviously metastasizes
Beyond social media and it's a culture
of you know yelling at people uh of
finding any way in which someone has
committed an infraction ction and and
going wild on it um it's a culture of
kind of not taking people aside and
saying hey quietly hey you know you
might want to think about what you said
in the meeting but instead going
straight to social media and dumping on
someone you like uh and admire and work
with but feeling an obligation to dump
on them publicly at L you be held
complicit um I have certainly
participated in call out Culture by the
way I think call out culture is also
very effective for certain things
there's elements of which you know uh I
think if you look at um the the rising
cries for racial Justice around the
world um the old approaches of trying to
work within the system were quite
ineffective and so calling out abuses of
power and things like that very useful
you know I think a lot of women have
found their voices calling out
patriarchy and sexism in the workplace
in ways their mothers and grandmothers
didn't have the tools to do and it's
been very effective so
there's a lot of power in calling out
also the problem is when our Democratic
discourse becomes dominated by trying to
kind of dunk on people instead of invite
them into the better tomorrow that we
want and so I read about Letta Ross
who's an veteran racial Justice
reproductive Justice gender justice
advocate in the US in her 70s now been
an activist for more than 50 years
really a kind of godmother of the
movement for so many people
and has The credibility no one thinks
she's a moderate or a milk toast mushy
middle person this is a serious serious
person who has fought serious fights and
lived hard realities to to seek the
world she wants and in recent years she
got very alarmed by this call out
culture and she says you know the
antidote is call-in culture and she
defines a call-in as a call out done
with love which is to say a Callin is
not not calling out it's not keeping
it's not ignoring the patriarchy or the
or the or the racist thing that you saw
at work it's calling out with love it's
finding ways to invite people in to a
the world you want now it's very
important to make distinctions there are
some people who are militantly racist
and militantly this is their ideology
they they they're making the comment at
work because they actually believe women
are the second sex like and you have to
be clear who those people are and you
need one strategy for them Loretta says
and then there's a lot of other
people who simply were not socialized in
gender equality and are a little too old
to have gotten the memo in time when
they were malleable and there's a lot of
white people who honestly never thought
about race until they were 40 years old
right and now suddenly it's everywhere
and there's trainings and there's TV
shows and they're a little bewildered
right and there's also people who want
to like burn churches because you know
and and I think in some ways l is threat
assessment that progressives have gotten
bad at threat assessment making the
distinction between the person who wants
to burn down your church and the person
who doesn't understand what the term
white supremacy means or the person who
makes an awkward comment at work about
women versus the person who wants women
back in the 14th century um both are
problems to be clear both are problems
but they're different kinds of problems
and the different scales of problems and
this former group of people who are
confused bewildered don't quite get it
we need them in our movements we don't
need them we driven to the other side
and we don't really want them Standing
Outside in the Rain banging on the door
getting frustrated no one's coming in
and eventually drifting away into the
night we want to pull them in we need
movements that are self-confident enough
to pull you in even if you don't know
the terms even if you don't get it even
if you say slightly awkward things
movement self-confident enough to
educate you inside in our spaces you
don't have to be perfect on your own
time to only then come in this
broadcaster asked me in response to my
own statement of unbelief he said I
insist that you answer the following
question and that you answer it with a
yes or a no I braced myself I accepted
the challenge
unseen he said you are to imagine
yourself in a strange city where you've
never been before you are to imagine
Nightfall coming on and you to be
without friends or sucker in this town
and you to you are to ask yourself
whether you would feel safe safer or
less safe when you saw a dozen men
coming towards you in the
dusk if you were to know that they had
recently come from a prayer
meeting this is the I'm I'm I'm I think
I can justifiably say I'm relaying to
you comrades friends brothers sisters
the challenge that was put by the
religious to me you'll see at once it's
not a yes no answer you can't give a yes
no answer to that but I accept it anyway
I said very well I won't give a Sesame
Street reply but just without leaving
the letter B I have been in that
situation in Bombay in Belfast in Beirut
in Belgrade in Baghdad and many other
places I won't tell you about all of
them but let me just let me just as it
were fill in some of those uh
latent uh
blanks um in Belfast the capital city of
one of the provinces of this our United
Kingdom as everybody here
knows everything culturally
educationally
economically politically socially has
been very Gravely for at least
a quarter of a century excuse me at
least half a century maybe more since
partition and before that because
partition is both the uh outcome and the
cause of sectarian Warfare in this town
by the simple fact that there are people
there who are willing to kill
not just one another but one another's
children on the basis of what kind of
Christian they
are horrible things are done not just in
pubs and clubs but on the streets on
housing Estates uh on University
campuses uh in that City still despite
the relatively good news we've had uh
today where the situation remains
dominated by barbaric sectarian Party
leaders on this and no other basis uh
both churches demand demand that their
children are sent to separate schools
they each agree with the other that
Above All Things their own children must
be protected from the faith of another
Faith uh I don't think I need to
elaborate very much more on uh how
horrendous the consequences of that have
been and how they are enshrined by the
way in our own Constitution which
mandates that our own head of the
church is uh also the head of the state
and of the Armed
Forces um with all the ludicrous Windsor
consequences that you get if you found a
National Church on the family values of
Henry
VII these conditions which are faral in
England Wales and Scotland are tragic
and ugly only a few minutes flying time
from where we sit if I pass on from
Belfast to say Baghdad where I've
recently been and without reopening any
of the arguments about the rightness or
otherwise of of the coalition
intervention in Mesopotamia I think it
can be granted by any fair-minded person
that what was most needed in Iraq after
30 years of fascism and War was a period
of
reflection a short interlude of
calm during which Iraqis could look
about themselves and decide perhaps whom
they'd like to vote perhaps what kind of
country they'd like to live in what kind
of federal system they might wish to
evolve and to do so unmolested by
violence or Terror the parties of God
have vetoed every hope of that process
the parties of God now have the Iraqi
people in their jaws and they're saying
to them it's not enough just to kill
foreigners or to rail against Jews uh or
Christians or secularists that's nothing
like enough uh it's only in Iraq uh not
only mainly chiefly in Iraq that it's
considered perfectly all right in fact a
religious Duty uh to blow up the mosques
to destroy the religious schools of
other Muslims of the Muslims of another
school not unlike the pattern of Belfast
it's not enough to have faith you must
have the right version of your own faith
or risk death mutilation and humiliation
and the the destruction that the IM
miseration the torture of Iraqi Society
is something that all of us can read
about every day suppose we're to go to
Beirut the pearl of the Levant the most
civilized and and beautiful and cultured
uh city of the Middle East and to see
what happens when for for politicized
reasons a sectarian Constitution is in
place which says that the president of
of Lebanon must always be a marinite
Christian that the speaker of its
Parliament must always be a Shia that
its vice president must always be a
Sunni that the Drews must have their
share and so on leaving out at the very
bottom I'm afraid such forces as Kurds
and Armenians but making everyone
defined in their citizenship by their
faith don't jinx it as we Muslims say
don't NZ me don't give me evil eye I
need to put food on the table I need
guests to come on my show but it is a
it's a question a lot of people ask um
when I did Eric Prince a lot of people
ask why did Eric Prince come on your
show and I to explain who he Eric Prince
is the former CEO of Blackwater
mercenary company it's the probably one
of the most viral interviews I've ever
done it actually got ended up with him
getting referred to the Department of
Justice for a criminal investigation for
alleged perjury because I called him out
for contradictions in his testimony and
people said afterwards Eric Prince this
Republican Trump supporting mercenary
why would he come on your show and I I
said I don't know if I was Eric Prince I
wouldn't have come on my show but I'm
glad he did thank you Eric Prince helped
my career a lot um I don't know why
people come on the show there's a
mixture of reasons I can only speculate
some people like John Bolton they just
enjoy a r Bolton's been debating since y
University they're very Uber confident
in their own abilities and I respect
that it's good let's let's do it I like
people you know who want to have a good
argument in good faith um some people
are ignorant they don't do their
homework they don't don't know anything
about the show when they turn up I did a
and some colleagues of mine from alaz
English here tonight I did an interview
with a senior government official from a
country I won't name who came on a show
I did and as they sat in I could see
them that was a remote interview and I
heard them say to an aid what is this
show who's this host I was like you
really should have asked that days ago
before you turned up to do the injury
and surprise surprise that government
then complained to alaz and the cat
government afterwards so ignorance
arrogance some people are just on a book
tour so they sit down for any interviews
um it's become harder as I've become uh
slightly more wellknown in the US being
Al English gave me a certain anonymity
uh in an American audience at least um
but yes it's become much more difficult
it's also become more difficult Johnny
because the people I really want to
interview some of these kind of
right-wing crazies are so crazy I don't
actually want to give put them on my
show there's a chapter that's not in the
book which is when do you not have an
argument when do you walk away from an
argument and I you know I'll interview
John Bolton as repulsive as I find his
politics
because I I know that he believes what
he's saying I don't think he pretends to
support the Iraq War he genuinely
believes that was he thinks it was the
right thing to do he doesn't think he
did anything wrong and he's clearly an
intelligent person even if I don't like
him but would I have like a Marjorie
Taylor green on my show no because I
just election deniers no climate change
denies no Holocaust deniers no I'm not
going to argue reality I'm not going to
argue Up Is Down black is white hot is
cold that stuff I won't do but people
who are willing to come on in good faith
even if they haven't done their homework
about me yeah bring it but as you said
more and more people are doing their
homework and people will you know the
show has a reputation and I'm wondering
if if in a way firstly they're going to
shy away from coming on your show but
also whether that one of the sadnesses
of the current polarized state of
particularly American life but I think
it maybe exist in other places is that
the kind of old school debate that you
embody and that you relish is happening
more and more rarely so that actually
people are in their silos speaking only
to their political family um and very
rarely are they colliding with the
opposite camp and in a way well it's you
know it's been great for you but you
know you're part of that because you're
on MSNBC most of the guests on MSNBC are
not John Bolton yeah they're actually
Democrats interviewing other Democrats
liberals interviewing other liberals
it's all very cozy and your show stands
out as something of an exception but do
you think it is a sort of endangered
form and that the network you work for
is part of the problem so it's
definitely an endangered form and I but
I don't think the part on the network
I'm not Su it cuz I'm employed and they
pay my bills but genuinely I I I kind of
I kind of get I get frustrated with this
msnbc's liberal Fox's conservative
Cable's divided America America is
divided for many many reasons well
beyond cable news also it's a symptom
not a cause yeah it's a sympt but also I
don't hide the fact that I do an opinion
show and I'm on a network that's
considered liberal left that's very
different to Fox Fox is not a News
Network Fox is a propaganda organ and
you don't have to take my word for it
just check out the leaked emails and
depositions from the fox Dominion case
that's going on right now where Rupert
modok admits under oath that his hosts
were lying and they endorsed a big lie
and maybe they shouldn't have where you
know Fox hosts are texting each other
saying well Trump's lawyers are crazy
and this stuff is mad and our viewers
they believe this stuff you know I tell
people you can loathe everything I say
on my show but I guarantee you I say the
same thing in private so I think the
best argument for porn is not the sexual
Liberation argument I find that
unpersuasive the idea that people just
ought to have some sort of human right
to have access to the most sort of
varied and depraved sexual acts you can
imagine being performed by strangers at
you know at the click of a mouse I don't
I don't find that persuasive we lasted
however many hundreds of thousands of
years as a species without access to
online porn I think we can probably cope
um the the probably the strongest
argument and it's sort of an empirical
argument and I haven't yet been
persuaded that it's true but this would
be if it were true this would be the
best argument in favor of porns
availability is that it um decreases
sexual violence that there are men who
if they have access to porn are less
likely to go and assault women offline I
mean I don't if that is true I really
don't love the idea of having these sort
of sacrificial Lambs women in the porn
industry who
are Ms well that's the big question so
it's an empirical question and it's just
really really hard to answer I think it
is unlik that that is true because if
you look at things like the way that
porn has changed sexual cultures and
sexual tastes so choking is the big
example or strangulation more accurately
used to be a niche within a niche you
know basically you don't hear about it
within the BDSM Community was which was
extremely marginal and was mostly
dominated by gay men now however it's on
the front page of every major porn
platform and all these shocking
statistics about how many um women in
their teens and 20s have been traed by
Partners often without any kind of
um warning you know yes um I think that
is clearly come that's a fashion that
has been cultivated by porn it is to
some extent feeding off um sort of
latent um sexual interest in both men
and women but it but it hasn't just shot
up in popularity spontaneously right
it's clearly an effect of porn so I
think the more likely um answer to the
empirical question of what po what
effect porn has on people is that it
molds both male and female sexuality to
this hyper hyper hyper capsul mode
basically that we they we all become
sort of in Hawk to whatever the
executives of mindgeek want us to be
watching yeah and I I know from
teenagers having talked to them a lot at
University and done various articles on
it that the girls will say that they're
being vanilla if they don't agree to
various acts and that they feel that
they are dull and boring and they are
expected to perform in certain ways and
Mary do you feel that that I mean that's
not just not progress in in many ways
it's very sad that women don't think
about their own enjoyment in sex as much
as what they're achieving for men do you
think that's that's part of it as well
that they haven't got
confidence I do I mean I pornography is
clearly a big part of what's what's
happened here I mean it's
like I think the thing which get which
sometimes gets misunderstood about porn
is that it's not it doesn't just it's
it's not just a set of images it's not a
static thing it's a it has a it has
force and direction in the sense that a
stimulus which you might watch and find
arousing um will wear off after a while
and so anybody who consumes a lot of
porn will start watching something
relatively innocuous you know two two
people at it and before and then after a
while that just doesn't do it anymore so
they go looking for something more
intense and they go looking for
something more and more intense and the
the the whole process eventually
inescapably leads people down these
sometimes really dark rabbit holes and
you obviously there's there are then the
performers who are who are incentivized
and sometimes coerced into performing um
you know in order to create this
increasingly extreme content but there's
also there's also the the effect it has
on on young people um in in terms of in
terms of how it shapes men's and women's
desires it very clearly affects them
differently in the sense that you know
most pornography is produced for male
consumers and it's produced you know
with a sort of grotesque caricature of
the male gaze and because it has this
force and direction in into increasingly
intense stimulus um that that that tends
that tends in the direction of
increasing violence increasing
objectification increasing degradation
bluntly um and for any young woman who's
exposed to even a small amount of this
material it's going to shape her
imaginary as well and inevitably that
means seeing herself from the man's
point of view in which which you know if
you consume enough talk in enough of
this material means you end up just more
or less unable to imagine yourself as
actually enjoying it or or only as able
to imagine enjoying something which
actually in practice in person is
horrible and
violent young women there's often I
think the same young women will say that
actually they should be allowed to wear
what they want and act how they want and
um drink what they want and I know
Louise you've got a list of things that
you shouldn't do as a woman if if you
want to stay safe but that would be seen
as fairly provocative by the younger
generation do you think they have to
start looking at this in a different
way uh yes it has been seen in there as
fairly provocative although um although
I should say actually I have been uh
Amazed by the response that I've had
from young women I mean the book has
been read as far as I can tell by just
by every demographic um but I wrote it
really for young women I wrote it really
the book I wish that I'd had when I was
and um it has had an enormous response
from those women and the thing that has
really struck me as someone who is so
I'm now 31 so I was a little bit um a
little bit too old to be properly online
you know we didn't get smartphones until
we'd um we're just about to leave school
and we're in University which which
which does hugely affect things like
your exposure to porn whereas a younger
generation obviously have grown up with
it and they're the guinea pig Generation
Um and it amazes me how um
how cowed girls are many of them by this
and how many girls will will I say girls
I mean you know ages sort of um up to
the age of maybe 25 will say I didn't
know this I didn't know that you were
allowed to object to Casual cultural
casual sex I didn't know that it was
okay to say that actually choking really
wasn't something you wanted to do you
know that on the one hand they're
bombarded with the consent message which
says You must consent to everything it's
a yes or no very clear sort of situ
situation but there's really no
conversation about the huge gray area
between you know legal consent and and
virtue and they find actually
negotiating that space almost impossible
um because they don't feel as if they
actually have permission to defend their
own interests so one of the things that
um I hope to do with the book and seem
to have done at least with some readers
is to um to offer that permission to say
actually it is okay to gatekeep your
body and to prioritize your own um
comfort over that of other people it's
something that young women find really
hard very often uh this is not simply is
there going to be a candidate I don't
believe that the elections are going to
be organized if Putin is running uh that
he's going to lose the elections but for
the first time President Putin is going
to be challenged not so much from those
who said why did you start this stupid
War but also of those who are saying why
you are not winning this bloody war so
for the first time the criticism to
Kremlin are coming not simply from the
liberal sources but also from a much
more extreme nationalistic position
saying okay you started but why you're
not winning and this creates a moment of
vulnerability it also creates a moment
of vulnerability because Russian
population was kind of quite ready to
live with the idea of the Special
Operation something like the large
version of Crema uh where basically the
Russian army goes succeeds in several
weeks and the people are just going to
cheer it in the way you cheer in as a
football team but now you have a
mobilization and probably you're going
to have a more mobilization and probably
they're going to be more than half a
million young men that are going to be
thrown uh to the battlefield and many of
them are going to be killed this is a
different social contract and from this
point of view President Putin is
vulnerable and he should try to find a
way to explain to the Russians why this
war is taking place of course his major
narrative is that he's not fighting
Ukraine he's fighting the west but if
he's fighting the West what is the
Victory and in my view this story to
explain the people what is a victory and
why they should suffer is going to be
very difficult and this is why the
election campaign is a moment of
vulnerability and my feeling is that the
Russian uh uh leaders Russian leader
knows very well
this and when we think about what
leaders are offering their people Jalen
zalinski
is popular of course uh he didn't flee
he stayed he's leading day by day but at
the same time he's Limited in any change
he can offer I'm I'm I assume that it's
going to be very hard for him to say
look we should talk to the Russians when
facing re-election himself totally and
from this point of view it's very
important that for Ukraine first is very
important to organize the elections and
listen it is not easy you organizing the
elections in a country in which the
majority of the population is not living
in the places in which they have been
living in the day the war started some
have been immigrated are they going to
vote some have been moved because of uh
of occupation and uh because of the
distractions so first and it's
critically important for Ukraine to show
the infrastructural capacity to organize
the elections and secondly uh of course
president zalinski is very popular but
president zilinski is very popular
because he's telling his own people I'm
not going to go on any comp romise I'm
not ready to do any type of a
territorial concession the moment he
said okay let's see what kind of
concession I can do be sure that there
going to be another candidate which is
going to run on the elections and saying
no this is not what we have been talking
about you have told to the people that
we're going to liberate all our
territory and this makes me believe that
for the same reasons we discussed about
Russia and Ukraine for both countries
it's going to be very difficult first to
have any meaningful negotiations in 2023
and secondly there is not good even
possibility for the conflict to freeze
in
2023 because in the elections in 2024 to
a great extent defining what is possible
and what is not possible and of course
what is happening on the ground is the
most important and in the wars what is
deciding decisive is really uh uh uh
what the armies are doing but this kind
of a very important constraints made it
very clear that president zalinski is
strong pressure to stay where he is and
to do what he has promised to do and to
be honest this is also true uh for
President Putin who is insisting we're
winning this is our land and so on and
obviously he's not winning at the moment
but he should try to convince his own
population that he's doing this so I'm
saying this because this type of a
perspective from the elections is not
going to tell us what is going to happen
but probably is going to help us to
understand what is not likely to happen
I was reassured that when there was
concerted pressure from the younger
generation but also from uh the people
potentially even the local governments
um that uh such a you know such a such a
a long-term kind of or or steadfast
policy was broken it shows that there
are mechanism this is a very important
point that there are mechanism embedded
in the systems uh whether it's from the
people and social media or the
competitive mechanism within the Chinese
government that makes it so that
preferences are still revealed and
potentially shape the outcomes of
political and economic decisions now of
course that is the ongoing challenge as
the Chinese government has to manage a
much more complex society going forward
not like the time when I was born and
everybody was content with having a
growing income today it's increasingly
complex but this new generation Young
Generation overturning a key policy was
more positive for me but we also forget
but but you said the preferences
revealed I mean they were revealed by
people demonstrating on the streets it
wasn't a particularly sophisticated
polling exercise absolutely but it's a
two-way monitoring system and social
media creates that kind of platform uh
not only for the Chinese government to
uh to watch what was happening on the
ground but other way as well and I think
that um basically um the the the complex
well anyway let me start over um I think
the complexity of the society is a big
challenge for the Chinese government and
they do listen they do listen now I
still think the O ongoing challenge is
how do you have the political mechanism
to include the much more important
participants of the economy like the
private businessman ENT entrepreneur in
that system if they don't do it and they
don't adapt the system is not going to
be as powerful or will uh enable the
Chinese dreams aspirations that it has
laid out yeah and he used the phrase the
Chinese Dream It's one that shishin ping
uses and he talks about the great
Rejuvenation of the Chinese people
people but I know some economists worry
that she is so statist uh as they see it
that he's in danger of killing that
entrepreneurial spirit and they Point
particularly to the fate of Jack Mah who
was the the icon of of Chinese business
appeared to say something or do
something the government didn't like and
is now as far as we know sort of
teaching students in Tokyo um he's
called back now oh really is he well
yeah well well tell me first what you
made of that episode but also more
broadly what it said about the
government's relationship with the most
dynamic business elements in society
well the first thing to note is broadly
speaking there can be a coexistence of
seemingly paradoxical and
irreconcilable uh things in China that's
something that perhaps a western
audience ought to keep in mind and that
no policy is permanent and they're
constantly being fued so the pretext of
this is uh Under the Umbrella of common
Prosperity under President XI how to
achieve Equitable growth but I think um
more may perhaps what the audience can
relate to is that uh in she's view China
doesn't want to be uh like the US highly
uh a high growth a great economy but
highly inequitable and uh politics sing
to the tunes of corporates China wants
an olive shaped income distribution
narrow on the ends and fat in the middle
it wants the corporates to sing to the
politics to sing to the tomes of politic
itics and so um this initial dramatic
sweeping Regulatory clampdowns and
technology companies that had
consequences for personalities and
private uh businessmen uh uh such as uh
Jack ma uh was of course a devastating
blow to the economy because of the
confidence issue um however did you wipe
a trillion dollars off the stock ex yes
it did because extraordinary because
American investors didn't couldn't make
what was was going to happen to the
private entrepreneurs and that's all
very understandable now that's a painful
lesson for the Chinese government
understanding that whatever they say
their intentions their Ambitions have
real economic and immediate Capital
markets consequences that was not the
case in the old Playbook which was
economy built on industrialization in
the new playbook around Innovation and
encouragement of entrepreneurs they have
to have credibility and commitment
something the Western Government
struggled with for a long period of time
to learn now is the learning process for
the Chinese government how ever that
said now you see in the recent past in
the recent last few months the state has
rolled back some of these heavy blows
invited jackma to come back and there's
a lot of luring private businessmen and
trying to restore that confidence
because guess what today's China's
economy the private sector is firmly in
the driver's seat and they do the heavy
lifting of the economy unlike during the
financial crisis of 2009 they call on
team China State Banks flush with cash
uh and State
Enterprises uh splurging on
infrastructure and you get the economy
back going that no long longer works so
even if the West believes that there's a
statist approach of President shei and
control on S soes the reality is that
pretty much everything about the economy
is driven by the private sector and the
government ke is keenly aware of
that